[Music]
cloud shell editor makes it easy for you
to run code from your web browser and
deploy it to the cloud
and google kubernetes engine makes it
easy to deploy
manage and scale your containerized
applications using google infrastructure
so you might be wondering can i write
the code for my google kubernetes engine
apps in cloud shell editor
yes you definitely can with its cloud
code integration
cloud shell editor gives you the power
to write code for your kubernetes
application
test and debug the app locally create
google kubernetes engine clusters
and finally deploy your app to a cluster
in this video
we're going to learn how to use cloud
shell editor to deploy an application
to google kubernetes engine let's go
first visit ide.cloud.google.com to
launch the cloud shell editor
on the status bar at the bottom of your
screen click cloud code
from the cloud code menu click new
application and then select kubernetes
application for the type of sample app
we want to create
after that we'll get a list of google
kubernetes engine samples to choose from
let's go with the go hello world option
next
select a folder in your cloud shell
environment to save your application to
and give it a name
if that looks good click create new
application
collateral editor loads the files for
your sample app into a new workspace
you can see the list of files in the
explorer panel located on the left side
of the screen
now let's go ahead and test our app
locally for this next section you will
run your application on a local
kubernetes cluster in cloud shell
in the top menu click terminal and then
new terminal
this opens up a new cloud shell terminal
window at the bottom of your screen
in your terminal run minicube start to
start your local mini cube cluster
once your cluster is set up you will see
a confirmation message
from the cloud code menu select run on
kubernetes and confirm that you want to
use the minicube context
the output panel displays the progress
as your app is built and deployed to the
local minikube cluster
once your app is built you can launch it
by hovering over the url link displayed
in the output panel and clicking
open web preview
congratulations if you see this page
that means you successfully run your
first app on kubernetes using cloud code
now let's go ahead and modify the app
to learn more about this hello world app
you can browse the files in the explorer
tab
at a high level it includes a go hello
world web app in maine.go
that returns a templated it's running
response to all receive requests
there's also a load balancer service
called go hello world external
and hello.service.gov that exposes the
app by describing a kubernetes service
now let's go ahead and modify the app
select the main.go file and replace
it's running with its redeploy
the file saves and rebuilds
automatically you can monitor your app's
progress in the output panel
this is cloud code's watch mode but it's
something you can turn off if you want
once your app finishes building and
deploying refresh your open tab to see
the updated app
to analyze your app while it's running
use the log viewer to monitor its logs
open the command palette by selecting
view find command
type cloud code view logs and click on
it
this opens up the log viewer which
allows you to filter and navigate the
logs for your app
in the deployment section select go
hello world
now refresh your app in the browser
come back to the log viewer and click
the logs refresh button to see new logs
you should see a new message for the
latest get request so far you've been
running your app locally
now it's time to push your app to a
remote cluster first
you'll need to create a new google
kubernetes engine cluster to deploy your
app to
click on the cloud code kubernetes icon
in the navigation bar
this kubernetes explorer makes
kubernetes development easier by
simplifying cluster creation
and management hover over the kubernetes
explorer bar and click on the plus sign
select create gke cluster
in the create cluster wizard select your
google cloud project
you'll need to select some properties
for the cluster you're going to launch
such as the zone or region
cluster name and any other selections
[Music]
click create cluster
cluster creation may take a few minutes
but once it's created your cluster is
listed within the kubernetes
explorer view finally let's deploy your
app to the new gke cluster
from the cloud code menu select run on
kubernetes
confirm your newly created cluster as
the context for your deployment
confirm the default option for your
image registry
once your app is successfully deployed
you can launch it via the link displayed
in your output panel
congratulations you've just created and
run your first kubernetes app on gke
don't forget to delete your cluster
using the gke explorer to avoid any
unwanted charges
just right click your cluster and select
delete cluster
[Music]
want to try this out yourself check out
the interactive tutorial linked in the
description below
make sure to subscribe to the channel
and stay tuned for more cloud shell
editor videos
[Music]